bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
colombia en esta ocasión vamos a hablar
sobre la desaparición forzada a
propósito del día internacional que se
conmemora el 30 de agosto además
tendremos una entrevista con una víctima
del movimiento nacional de víctimas de
crímenes de estado y con la directora de
la unidad de búsqueda de personas dadas
por desaparecidas en colombia con quien
profundizaremos más de este delito que
según naciones unidas es utilizado como
una estrategia de control para infundir
terror en las poblaciones
[Música]
colombia ocupa el primer puesto en
número de casos de desaparición forzada
según el informe de la onu publicado en
2020 la comisión de la verdad dijo que
entre 1985 y 2016 unas 121 mil personas
desaparecieron forzosamente
y que podrían ser más altos debido al
subregistro ya que se estima que las
víctimas alcanzarían las 210.000 en
colombia muchos de estos crímenes han
sido cometidos por grupos armados
ilegales como lo muestra el informe
final de la comisión de la verdad donde
los responsables de la desaparición
forzada en colombia fueron el 52% grupos
paramilitares el 24% la desmovilizada
guerrilla de las farc ep el 9% grupos
paramilitares en asocio con fuerza
pública o del gas entidad de
inteligencia del estado que ya
desapareció 8 % agentes estatales 3%
guerrilla de ln y 4% otros grupos la
comisión de la verdad hace un recorrido
de cuando las desapariciones forzadas
empezaron a ocurrir de forma masiva en
el país datan de la época de finales de
los 80 cuando se decretó un estatuto de
seguridad que permitía perseguir a
sospechosos de pertenecer a grupos de
guerrilleros según la misma comisión
hacia mediados de los 80 esos crímenes
se incrementaron en 54% debido a
procesos de paz con grupos insurgentes
surgimiento de nuevos partidos políticos
que fueron perseguidos entre 1991 y 2002
los grupos paramilitares fueron los
grandes victimarios además ya en este
siglo en el año 2007 hubo un nuevo pico
de desapariciones en gran medida por el
rearme paramilitar amnistía
internacional señala que un porcentaje
alto de las víctimas de la desaparición
forzada no son liberadas o mueren a
manos de sus captores pilar navarrete
familiar de una de las tantas víctimas
desaparecidas nos cuenta sobre su
proceso en la búsqueda de héctor jaime
una persona que desapareció en el año
1985 termina en la retoma del palacio
social que fue el 7 de noviembre de
1985 a las cuatro de la tarde empezamos
la búsqueda de él en
guarniciones militares en hospitales en
clínicas por las calles pues casi por
30 años buscamos en diferentes lugares
cuando se cumplen 32 años de su
desaparición
a raíz de la sentencia de la corte
interamericana que obligó al estado
colombiano a entregarnos los vivos o
muertos
se ordenan las exhumaciones de todas las
personas que habían sido
enterradas en este tiempo del 85 y se
dan cuenta que había sido entregado a la
familia del magistrado julio césar
andrade como su papá la jurisdicción
especial para la paz iep ha ayudado al
esclarecimiento de los crímenes o por lo
menos que los victimarios
paramilitares guerrilleros y ex miembros
de la fuerza pública pidan perdón por lo
ocurrido la ong amnistía internacional
impulsa entre otros temas a los
gobiernos a que investiguen y procesan a
los responsables en un juicio justo
legislen para incorporar la convención
internacional a la legislación nacional
y se aseguren de que los sobrevivientes
y los familiares que han perdido a sus
seres queridos reciban compensación la
directora de la unidad de búsqueda de
personas
por desaparecidas en colombia nos da un
balance tras la firma del acuerdo de paz
con las farc en 2016 que hoy a pesar del
acuerdo a pesar de estar asumiendo la
búsqueda y estar asumiendo una
responsabilidad de esclarecimiento pues
las personas las siguen desapareciendo y
hay unas modalidades que son horrorosas
y que hacen presente que esa cláusula
constitucional de la prohibición
absoluta de la desaparición pues no se
cumpla que mientras no haya
esclarecimiento sobre lo que ha pasado
con las personas desaparecidas pues no
puedes a tener una información
exacta de para decir en la persona fue
desaparecida forzadamente la persona
está es secuestrada o la persona lo que
pasa es que ya la mataron o lo que sea
esto qué está pasando con estas bolsas
que están apareciendo diariamente en
bogotá con cuerpos pues son personas que
hipotéticamente están desaparecidas los
esfuerzos de los familiares las en eje y
el estado por encontrar a los miles que
han sufrido desaparición forzada en
colombia no parecen suficientes muchas
de las víctimas eran sin aparecer y solo
queda la memoria de los que los
conocieron para que no sean olvidados
agradecemos al centro de memoria paz y
reconciliación por permitirnos grabar en
este espacio sigue con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom